video strategy guys so what is this um
it's a service product uh more an
information depend on how you structure
but I mean we'll deal with that in a
second but it helps people I'm assuming
level up their video game skills and
complete games
faster
um I mean I could add a personal line
here as far as whether or not I like the
business or not from uh you
know essentially from the standpoint of
whether or not it resonates with me
versus I'm opposed the business metric
like I for example I don't think it is
the greatest use of a man's time to
level up a video game character in a
game versus leveling themselves up in
real life people will spend not even
hours or days or weeks sometimes months
and even years of their life playing
video games to level up a character
again this is an avatar in a game a
fictional world to earn whatever the
currency you know happens to be you know
gold bullion bullion whatever the hell
you know but they'll make up you know
sort of currency within most games um I
can make an entire video on how they
hook you and and and get you sucked in
on that com below if that's something
you're interested in in the future but
they'll spend all this effort and
resources leveling up in a game but be a
loser in real life and it's fine if
you've done something with your life you
get it you've done something you put Den
Universe you something significant to
solve problems you're doing something in
the real world making real money solving
real problems with real people and have
a real good Network and you're like
I'm gonna put my feet up and play video
game side that's different you've
already done the work relax put your
feet up for an hour or two play video
game I'm addressing specifically people
that spend way too much time video games
so this business model that was
presented to me here
is um video game strategy guides and the
description that I got on that was to
accelerate and skills faster to complete
games faster and level up faster so
let's evaluate this business idea do you
need
employees um no probably not this is
something that you could generally run
yourself so I'm going to give it a 10
okay what we're going to is we're going
to score these up at the bottom and take
a look across then this will easily
demonstrate to us which business stands
out which would be a good business to
run which one would be or which one
would generally not be the best ones to
run so I'm GNA put a 10 there because
you could probably do this yourself uh
throughout its entirety recurring
Revenue um if you built a community into
it if you built some sort of recurring
uh billing assistance this would be
ideal if you're building something for a
video game or or see if you do something
where it's a one hit wonder um Flappy
Bird would be an example nobody not many
people know what Flappy Bird is watching
this right now because it's it's G to
date me back all over a decade but
Flappy Bird was a game that people
played um
2008 or 10 like in and around that space
or so and it was the stupidest freaking
game ever uh I think it sold for quite a
lot of money when it sold and it sold
very very quickly but everybody was
talking about and playing it but if you
wrote strategy guide for something like
Flappy Bird it's an in and out it's a
oneit wonder versus something like Zelda
or World of Warcraft which has a large
Following over a long period of Time
games where you level up from level one
to 80 to 160 and you know so on and so
forth in the perpetuity keep players in
for a longer period of time so the
chances of building the current Revenue
are far greater so if you're going to do
a video game strategy guard those are
the types of games that I would
recommend targeting can you build
something with recurring Revenue
absolutely I'm them is it
sellable um something is generally
sellable if you have either recurring
revenue or if you have a book of
business like uh a list of customers um
with something like this I'm gonna say
yes although I don't think the market
would be that great so I'm going to
score it an eight there uh can sales
grow to $1 million a
year not easily and maybe with some
potential and some work um youd have to
build a large business out of this um
which is going to require the need for
employees contractor so that 10 will go
down and maybe you could throw a number
here I'm I'm generally speaking for the
vast majority of people that are going
to sell video game strategy guys I'm
gonna say probably not so I'm gonna give
this a five because it's not the type of
business that I would deem um you know
worth more than a million dollars a year
in annual sales is it in high
demand probably is I think there's a lot
of people that play video games although
I don't know how many people that play
video games need strategy guides so this
is going to be a bit of a guess but I'm
GNA give it to 7.5 is it location
independent absolutely this something
you can run from anywhere in the world
government regulations govern's not
probably not going to bother you with
this I'm I'm not going to say
definitively not going to bother you
with this but chances are very very low
there's going to be attorney generals
FTC regulations governing how you write
your gu guides what's in the guide how
you how you charge for the guide when
you release the guide information it's
unlikely um can it be bootstrapped yes
absolutely uh is it a painkiller or a
vitamin it's more of a painkiller I'm
going to go with so it's I'm gonna put
on the higher end although it's not
something that's in higher demand like
healthwise right like if you get up in
the morning and your health is
completely deteriorated and you've
suffered you're going to know about it
you have to deal with it video games
more of a luxury so I'm going to give
this around seven ease of marketing I
think it would be reasonably easy to
Market this um you could Target people
that um are in Facebook groups social
groups communities uh that talk about
certain uh games you know they play you
can even dedicate a YouTube channel to
it I mean Minecraft has loads of YouTube
channels that are dedicated to it um so
I think the ease of marketing is
reasonably High fact I'm going to change
a seven to an eight now that I've sort
of brain through that you guys are
seeing how my mind works here right
Freedom um yeah you can pretty much run
this business at any time of the day
anywhere in the world so I'm going to
score that high I'm give it at least an
eight and is it an info service or a
physical product it is not a physical
product unless you do print strategy
guides which you can do on Amazon um if
you do digital strategy guides uh
courses you know more specifically then
it's it's it's definitely more of an
easy fun type of business so um while
there might be the need for some
physical like books you know for
example um it doesn't take much to
publish on Amazon be honest with you you
don't have to print the books and Shi
them like they take care of all of that
for you so it's reasonably high as far
as the business model goes low business
models are physical products if you take
a physical product again we're gonna use
our calculator here our trusty
calculator you're G to have to procure
these you have to find a factory that
makes this which I'm guessing
probably comes from China this one says
Tre some sh like that on the back far as
a brand and it is made in China of
course as Donald Trump would say China
so this is a Chinese product you would
probably go to Alibaba find this
you could buy one crate of it you could
buy a shipping container it you could
buy five Shi containers of it
more cost it's reason be robust but
things will break the solar display the
screen could could break you could have
issues with shipping things could get
lost shipping returns with shipping So
Physical products for me score are lower
on business ideas than information or
service based products so you understand
the difference now because we're talking
about a video game strategy guide it's
more digital or you could print them off
Amazon which is reasonably easy so I'm
going to give it about an eight okay so
let's uh score this up where is
the button got 11 cyber security courses
so this guy mentioned creating
implementing and monitoring security
plans for your
company I like this business a lot more
than video game strategy guides so I'm
not giving it a rich score or anything
like this but if I had to this would get
a 10 like Rich score sounds like I'm
talking about like Doug deiro right the
Doug score
um so we got creating implementing and
monitoring security plans for companies
so let's let's do this um let's just
sort of brainstorm so this is a
service-based uh probably software is a
service service based type of product
and what they'll do is they'll probably
Pro poke at and monitor your security
plan on a consistent basis uh to make
sure everything's up and running the
firewalls work um backups are working um
like there's all kinds of bags out
there get into I'm going to tell you
right now there are people out there
that have nothing better to do with
their time and they will pick and C at
businesses and then then if they can get
through your security measures they'll
uh capture your database or your
customer list or customer credit card
numbers and then what you'll get is an
email from like you'll go into work one
day and you'll try to log in you won't
be able to access your and you'll
be like yourself be like I can't log
into the system I can't open files it's
all gone your it guy looks at it and he
goes we got hacked right right some mofo
from country somewhere that you
barely know how to pronounce the name of
the city du to sent you an email send me
seven Bitcoin otherwise you're not going
to get your database back so cyber
security is a viable business people get
uh like hit hard and it's very costly to
them so to pay a little bit money a
month for something that uh creates
implements monitors and probes your
plans for your business I think is a
great idea so what's the first one here
need for employees
unfortunately yes so we're going to
score this pretty low I'm not a big fan
of having staff okay a lot of what I
talk about in my course at the School of
Entrepreneurship um encourages you not
to have employees for a whole bunch of
Reason I'll give you some right now I
get into greater lengths within all the
course material but for example problem
with employees is they're very expensive
they're very inefficient uh if you can
automate or Outsource something it's far
better than having an employee minimum
wage keeps going up you've got Source
deductions you've got payroll taxes
Employment Insurance health insurance T
you got all these deduction
sources to pay either an employee and or
the government it's usually both
obviously and then you've got issues
with they call in sick they're banging
each other HR getting calls over
all kinds of they're
inefficient there there's an old joke
that um you know I heard in the circles
when I was traveling at entrepreneur and
it was something along the lines of um
you ask an employee how long they've
worked there and then their answer as
the employee is ever since they starting
to fire me so the employee will do this
much which they think is what the what
the maximum or you know what their
requirement of the job is to be
compensated for the pay generally the
employer expectation is up here so
there's this
Gap most employees think that this is
what they need to do to get their pay
this is employers thing employees are
not the best way to go forward with
businesses and then you've got all kinds
of weird that you're dealing with
today like there's most people that
you're gonna hire are not a players it's
very very difficult to get a players so
avoiding employees where possible is a
good idea actually I'm going to change
this now that I've sort of brainstormed
this through a little bit so need for
employees because I think you can
Outsource a lot of this not a lot but
you can out a lot of it I'm G change to
four recurring Revenue absolutely yeah
you would definitely put every customer
on a recurring Revenue model pay X
number of dollars a month 297 997 you
know 27 13 whatever the hell it happens
you know it's GNA be a monthly repairing
plan for sure it's like software as a
service uh is it sellable yeah yeah
definitely sellable um and it grow
sales2 million doll a year yes it
can absolutely these these business are
extremely lucrative it in high demand
demand the problem with the with the
demand factor for cyber security courses
is people demand them after they've
either been hit or somebody else hit
them mo and most people don't think
about this as a new startup so so you
want to Target medium to large siiz
businesses because they've got the
bandwidth of the money and they've
probably been hit or hurt of something
that's been hit so depending on on how
you structure it definitely a high
demand I'm going to give it a
nine location independent
um
potentially um I'm going to give it a 12
because there's gonna be some
requirement for face to face for for
many of this um not a ton but there's
gonna be some requirement government
regulations they're going to exist but
not to a high degree so I'm going to
give this like a 10 for government regs
because government won't be up your ass
about this too too much going to be
bootstrapped yeah yeah I would say so
that's uh out of 15 I'm going to give
this a uh a
13 take some programming work painkiller
or vitamin more of a painkiller so
that's a Goods model so we'll give it a
10 and ease of
marketing uh if you Market to midsize
and large siiz businesses uh reasonable
yet we'll call it a nine Freedom not
really you're going to be on call a lot
for this sort of because you get
calls on the weekends until you grow the
business to a substantial size and
you've got um people that are able to
answer phones or it team that can deal
with this sort of stuff so Freedom
aspect not very much in the early stages
but maybe build it a little higher later
on but I'm G to give it a five right now
and let's go with um infos service
product it is definitely a information
taged service product it's not a product
it's definitely a service because it's
referring revenue of the no physical
product to move around in the m
you don't need a warehouse you don't
need a physical retail outlet a location
like a Walmart or any of that it's
just more less a service so exact box
we're call that a 10 let total this up
and we'll compare these all in a second
towards the end so that's one22 that's
scored better that's scored better than
a video game strategy guy I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out